today we're going to be speaking with
catherine judge who's the harvey j
goldschmidt professor of law at columbia
law school and also author of the book
direct the rise of the middleman economy
and the power of going to the source
really great having you on i appreciate
your time
yeah thank you for having me
so um i think intuitively many in our
audience will will understand the
concept of of middlemen in the global
economy
and
my instinct is that at some point it was
quite logical to start seeing middlemen
as um
we started to see many industries scale
international trade you know we could
think of reasons why why it made sense
what are the origins of so many
middlemen in so many of the industries
with which we regularly engage
i mean you really hit on a lot of the
drivers so the the middlemen are the
connectors through whom goods flow
through money flows from people who have
it to those who need it
and both as the economy got more global
but also as it got more specialized
we saw proliferation of middlemen
helping to facilitate those transfers so
you might have you know investors with
excess capital in one country
and limited opportunities for return and
so you ended up initially as one and
subsequently oftentimes layers of
middlemen that would help facilitate
flows to where there might be productive
undertakings uh even if that meant kind
of going moving the money abroad
similarly in production uh we know games
from trade is a classic idea and of
course we've had a shift from just
having goods imported from one country
to another
to really having globalized supply
chains where goods are made in a
multi-continent undertaking with each
step kind of undertaking what it can do
most efficiently but of course as you
have that disaggregation of production
you need middlemen to help connect each
step along the way so before we we talk
about some of the downsides i mean it
seems accurate to say that in many cases
consumers do see lower prices on many
products as a result of middlemen is
that fair
that's certainly fair and one of the the
points of the book is actually middlemen
usually arise because they're really
providing significant value and it
explores how overcoming the
informational and logistical challenges
uh that can otherwise impede
transactions that make everybody better
off is a real value enhancing service to
provide so middlemen themselves are at
this point really the backbone of the
economy they're not going to go anywhere
soon but what the book explores is that
in a static environment you can look at
take a snapshot and it looks like
they're providing a lot of value and
oftentimes they are
but the very nature of what makes them
so good at their jobs
also gives them the ability to exercise
outsized influence on the evolution of
the market and the evolution of the laws
that are governing the spaces where
they're active that sometimes allows
them to extract more value and and lead
to potentially other challenges in
future periods so and when you say that
you it because if i think of like
walmart and amazon
walmart and amazon
are middlemen in a sense in that they
don't manufacture most of the products
they sell so in a sense they've created
this marketplace very convenient for all
sorts of different products but they
also will contract with other middlemen
in many cases as well so so they both
are
middlemen and also are not depending on
which relationship we're thinking of
yeah and one of the interesting points
is when you look the term middlemen
itself is very it's easy to define in
the abstract but when you're trying to
apply that to particular companies part
of what you realize is a lot of middle
and men do provide additional value
along the way so their primary role
might be helping to overcome
informational or logistical challenges
but oftentimes they're doing other
things in the process right
um and so the the goal is to say look
it's not going to ever be a clean line
but conceptually it's helpful to
understand companies that are primarily
engaged in this business of connecting
and amazon and walmart are among them
they certainly have other activities
that they engage in amazon with
something like amazon web services is
providing a completely different
type of value proposition but but much
of what they do is make it so american
consumers can very readily access
and have enough information to trust to
buy goods that were made on the other
side of the world so there's
efficiencies there and there's a real
connection that's provided but there's
drawbacks one of the things that i think
is a concern for many in my audience
from the things we've talked about is
the ways in which sometimes very large
corporations will use middlemen and or
contractors to um
avoid accountability in some cases
sometimes point the finger at some other
entity you know the amazon delivery
services is one where
often the vans that we all see driving
around are not actually owned and
operated by amazon even if they have
amazon painted sometimes it's local llc
delivery companies that own a bunch of
vans or you know there's different
things is this one of the concerns with
this infrastructure where you have all
these different parties
it is one of those very significant
concerns uh so part of the challenge is
you know if you're just going directly
to the creator of a good not only
there's a relationship there but there's
clear accountability and any information
you want about that good you can readily
ascertain by asking the person or asking
for representations and warranties if
you want to be legalistic
about the
the product but also about the nature of
how it was made and who was impacted
and part of what the book shows is that
much of the complexity of today's supply
chains and the structure of these layers
of intermediaries grew up at a time
where we just assumed investors wanted
to maximize the risk-adjusted returns
and
consumers wanted nothing more than the
lowest price good you know holding
quality constant according to some
objective measures but now we're in a
world where people suddenly realize the
government can't solve all of our
problems we actually care more about the
impact of the goods on the planet on the
workers and both through intentional
use of of middlemen to offspring but
also just a byproduct of really complex
chains that were not necessarily
designed to create opacity but as a
practical matter have created that
opacity it is now virtually impossible
at times to understand i mean you can
look at your breakfast cereal and trying
to figure out where it all came from is
is oftentimes beyond the the average
consumer's capability and so as we're
bringing these additional values to the
table the accountability that people now
want is oftentimes very difficult if not
impossible to glob on top of the current
system yeah i mean in the kind of like
hipster lefty space that i occupy
there's been a big move in the last five
years to go towards you know craft and
independent producers and products that
are not as widely available sometimes
that in and of itself is what makes them
more interesting
and and i do think that there is value
to that because you know if you think
about like the the coffee roasting
industry instead of going to your
grocery store and grabbing the you know
allegro that's available nationally or
whatever you find some local roaster and
it's more interesting and you know who's
roasting it but it's almost always more
expensive and so it it does seem that
there is a very clear
advantage at least in the minds of
consumers to that but there is certainly
a price associated with it
yeah and i want to say a couple things
on that so first i love the coffee
roasting example one of the examples of
my books is roost roosters which was a
local coffee roaster you know and i knew
them when they were small and they kept
growing but it is really nice and one of
the nice things about going direct is
even though it's more expensive you not
only learn a lot but you know where the
money's going so i actually feel a
little better about the money i'm
spending because i know the company i
know it's a local business i know all
the people involved i know how they
treat their employees so so i actually
feel better about the money i spent and
that is partly shifting from a world
where
we had long assumed scarcity to one
whereas a practical matter
even though we still have a scarcity
mindset because that's how we're taught
to think so often we really live in a
world of abundance so making more
selective choices is oftentimes more
rewarding which is part of why you're
seeing the trends you are
the final point i would make is even
though that's very often true that right
now direct is a little bit of a
privileged good or seems like a
privilege guide
um it's more pervasive than people
realize outside of cities so i get this
question all the time from people who
live in relatively urban environments i
live in an urban environment um but
right now i'm out on our country and
part of what's been interesting since i
published the book is i'm hearing from
people in south carolina and ohio in all
of these different states where they say
this is exactly what's already happening
in my community and actually there
they're keeping all of the value in
their community and they're not
necessarily playing as much as a premium
because it's not the craft artisan that
we think about in brooklyn or or kind of
like a fun neighborhood as much as
somebody who's really just like trying
to create make additional money by doing
a product or a service on the side and
maintains competitive by having good
prices it's not going to be as cheap as
the mass produced good in walmart partly
because there you're exploiting kind of
this
incredibly low wage and worker
protections uh in other places but you
really can um
i think hit a broader set of the the
value spectrum that many of us
appreciate when it comes to supply chain
and some of the issues that we saw
early in the pandemic and then sort of
again and then even now to some degree
and we've seen baby formula in different
things
it's not completely obvious to me as
someone who does not share your level of
expertise in this issue
whether the problem was made worse or
was actually resolved more quickly
by the kind of status quo of many
middlemen in terms of supply chains and
the way that products kind of get to the
shelves and ultimately into people's
homes
what is the relationship or the
connection between those supply chain
issues we've seen over the last three
years and the existence of middlemen
so
i would say in terms of the the risk
what we've seen arise it really can be
traced back to the proliferation of
middlemen um
but even the middlemen of as you point
out i think accurately played a role in
helping us to address the challenges
part of what the direct documents
is the way
middlemen proliferated slowly in number
to become more layered in ways that
really created these complex ecosystems
and generally speaking nobody took a
step back to look at the entire complex
ecosystem they were thinking we could
eat a little more
cost savings here a little more
efficiency there and so they kept making
decisions that incrementally were small
but an aggregate transformed the nature
of the system
and then as we saw once there were
shifts whether it's these spike in
demand or or limitations of supply
because countries of origins you know
were facing shutdowns there were ripple
effects that magnified
that original distortion
because you had all these suddenly
individual
players that had depended on the system
working well
um
having to figure out how to signal you
know what they wanted what they needed
in ways were they really looking out for
themselves and so you suddenly ended up
with people wanting like demanding for
more than they actually needed because
they were trying to hoard and and really
the distortions kept getting bigger and
what's interesting for me is that this
was actually one of the original
motivations for the book
a lot of my original work was on
financial regulation and looking at the
way securitization chains
that proliferated in the early odds
contributed to the 07 and 08 crisis and
we saw the exact same thing there where
we saw these chains that grew so they
were capital supply chains as opposed to
good supply chains
but they grew incrementally over time
they appeared to make credit more
available so more people could buy homes
and that seemed like a really good thing
at the time because we could suddenly
tap in to these new pools of capital in
germany and japan to fund american homes
but we created an incredibly complex
ecosystem where once things broke down a
little
the the dysfunction magnified and nobody
had the information they needed to help
stabilize the the functioning yeah it
seems there's this interesting example i
remember from early in the pandemic
related to toilet paper where as you say
people started wasn't that people were
using more in total but they were buying
more meaning they would be stocked up
for a longer period of time and it was
shifting from being at work to being at
home and one of the questions a lot of
people were asking was well all of the
companies that deliver paper goods to
businesses
shouldn't they just be able to redirect
that and put it in grocery stores or at
cvs or whatever the case may be and part
of the explanation was well
we're talking about different packaging
these things are not packaged for sale
in the same way and that's done much
earlier in the supply chain often before
it gets to the middlemen the local
company that that you go to
also sometimes like the toilet paper
rolls for businesses are gigantic you
know it just doesn't work at home but
also
the companies doing the the commerce
servicing office buildings
don't have any connection whatsoever to
like cvs or staples or or whatever so
there were really a whole bunch of
things that would have had to change now
would it have been simpler if the toilet
paper manufacturers dealt directly with
everyone i don't know that would have
had its own share of problems
yeah and part of the book is really not
saying direct is the solution as much as
direct as the cornerstone and a
cornerstone really is a very very small
piece of a much larger edifice so the
point of saying we've gotten to this
hyper-intermediated world where
generally speaking the instinct was
always to add additional layers of
middlemen but as you nicely pointed out
earlier there's already a counter
movement underway there's already a
number of people saying to be able to
really get what i want to have my values
match my actions i need to opt out of
the system entirely and so by
documenting both the growth of this
hyper intermediate world and this
revolution well then we can figure out
how to to navigate this territory in
between and the toilet paper is a great
example of it uh so as you're pointing
out the nature of the supply chains had
incredible rigidities which just meant
like they were used to doing one things
and they couldn't easily change right
and oftentimes what we're seeing with
those rigidities the complexity really
accentuates them and it's not about
going direct but having
fewer middlemen and shorter chains can
oftentimes enhance resilience and
enhance flexibility so trying to figure
out where did we add layers
over time without anybody really
understanding well what are the states
of the world
uh where things might go wrong and where
that might create problems or going back
to our earlier conversation where there
might be a lack of accountability
because now there's just no way for us
to actually see through all of the
different layers involved there are some
industries where
there's been a move into a more direct
model one of the ones i think is
interesting is you know for for me the
experience of going to car dealers has
never been good i mean it's just it's
not a pleasant experience very low
uh satisfaction with it for the average
consumer i ordered my last car online
it's a tesla i didn't have to talk to
anybody i picked the features i wanted
there was no negotiation
and then i got a call when the car was
ready and it was a dramatically better
experience now this is all aside from
all the other concerns about elon musk's
tweets all these different things i get
that but as an experience the dealership
is a terrible experience and it seems to
me that it would only make the end
product more expensive one report says
on average people pay about twelve
hundred dollars more for vehicles than
they otherwise would because of the the
dealership experience another one that
as many real estate agents that i have
in my social circle that i think
could be eliminated is the idea that a
realtor
regularly takes you know a slice out of
every real estate transaction can sell
the same house multiple times in many
countries you just deal with a lawyer
and you don't need the entire
infrastructure of the real estate agent
it you could potentially cut out a
middleman can you talk about either of
those industries and or other industries
that have done well at moving to a more
direct model
so both absolutely outstanding examples
i spent a lot of time on residential
real estate and
the
car market fits equally well and i'd
actually done a huge amount of research
and only left it out because i had so
many other great examples so the great
thing about your tesla example is yes it
was a better experience and contrary to
our earlier conversation it was cheaper
you're cutting out an expensive
middleman and you're saving real money
and same thing in residential real
estate we know for your average middle
class family the median family united
states they don't have most of their
money in stocks and bonds
housing is our number one source of
wealth so when real estates come agents
come in and take five percent on average
even now of every single real estate
transaction you are eating directly out
of the bottom line the nest egg of your
typical middle class family in a very
meaningful way now many of the real
estate agents in their defense are also
middle class right i mean there's two
sides to that to be fair
yeah the hard thing with a real estate
agent is there's some really good
research just showing that we have too
many of them so they provide very real
value but it's relatively easy to become
a real estate agent so what we've seen
is there's some great work showing you
know comparing for example minneapolis
and boston and saying look when housing
prices were about the same uh each agent
sold on average like 10 houses a year or
12 houses a year and then suddenly the
boston housing market went crazy so a
decade later what happened
real estate agents in minneapolis were
still selling 10 to 12 houses a year
real estate agents in boston their
income was about the same but they were
suddenly selling on average four to five
houses a year and that's because so the
commissions went up because there were
percentage of sales so so many more
people became real estate agents and
then so what do they all do they send
out like really glossy mailings to
people who already own their homes just
saying like choose me if you're going to
sell so it's not actually against the
real estate agents themselves it's a
system that doesn't serve the agents and
really doesn't serve homeowners right
and one nice thing about both the the
car market and the real estate market is
they are examples
where
there have been state laws across
numerous states
that entrench the current system
so for example if you look at
penetration of electric vehicle sales
one of the
most significant indicators
is do you have state laws that
effectively entrench the the need to use
a car dealership doesn't new jersey have
such a law
yeah and i think so i should double
check but a number of a number of states
do and 10 states still have things
protecting effectively effectively
prohibiting rebates because really for
real estate it's the buy side more than
the sell side where one where a lot of
countries have managed to get rid of the
agent so oftentimes sellers need a
little more handholding but you're also
paying a lot to a buyer where they're
doing their own work on zillow or redfin
but of course what you're really tapping
into there is the mls which is still
controlled by full service real estate
agents and so those are both great
examples where when you really look at
the mechanisms they are layered and a
little complicated but where you see
people who came in originally and
provided value
and then in a post-internet era where
there's so much more ability for
consumers to do things for themselves we
should have had a change in the market
structure but the change has been
relatively modest
relative to the cost savings and the
alternatives that open up and it's
partly because
the
the entrenched middlemen really do a
good job
to
to undermine
the the alternatives that otherwise
would be available both through market
mechanisms and through through legal
mechanisms yeah justifying their own
their own existence essentially uh the
book is direct the rise of the middleman
economy and the power of going to the
source we've been speaking with the
books author catherine judge who teaches
law at columbia law school thank you so
much for your time today i really
appreciate it
thank you for having me